remember South Park the stick of truth
well South Park the fractured but whole
arrived this week and I am personally
enjoying the hell out of it it'll
definitely give you similar vibes to the
first game but certain elements are
different enough that there's probably
things you'll want to know before diving
in if that sounds like you here's a few
helpful tip it's your class isn't
permanent
you can change classes whenever you want
by sitting across from Cartman in the
Koon layer and there's no penalty for
changing as many times as you want
you'll always get rebooted into your
backstory stage which works as a
tutorial for each class so if you want
to see how all the different abilities
play this is a good way to do it you
will have to backtrack to solve puzzles
if you can't get into a certain area
going to inspection mode and hover over
what appears to be the solution to the
puzzle it will often tell you that
you're missing a necessary skill or
buddy to solve it this saves heaps of
time you would have spent trying to
solve the unsolvable if you want to be
smart to make a note of where you are
when you find an unsolvable puzzle if
not you'll find yourself in the
situation I'm currently in where I'm
wasting time backtracking around town
trying to find that one gas valve in
that one upstairs landing from way back
because I finally know what to do with
it if a puzzle seems impossible it
probably is you'll likely get the
ability to solve it later the puzzles in
the fractured but whole are satisfying
but not overly complicated equip your
best items and get crafty remember to
keep checking your inventory and
crafting menu for new items and recipes
you could have picked up a recipe for a
great out of fact that you can craft
immediately to boost your might level
when you pick up an item or hover over
it in the crafting menu there is a spot
on the description to let you know
whether the item is worth comparable or
better than your currently equipped
artifacts you can make multiple versions
of one artifact so feel free to double
up if one option is way better than all
your others healing items are pretty
simple to craft and invaluable in combat
so ensure you have tortillas on hand to
make your Mexican food healing potions
and you'll never be short a burrito in
battle basic crafting items are also
easily available from almost every
vendor and vending machine balanced your
party
when it comes to balancing you have a
few different choices you can tailor
your buddy selections to suit your
we custom character or because you can
change classes and abilities whenever
you can alter your character to suit
your design party this is what I did I
picked buddies who are mostly tanks with
protection and area buffs and made my
character one who could do damage from
afar lay on elemental effects and heal
the entire party with my ultimate
ability if necessary that said some
combat scenarios will suit certain
characters more than others if you have
a bunch of little foes you want to take
out quickly
you're a OE damage dealers are the best
bet however if you're fighting an ultra
damage dealing boss it's important to
have a healer on side for when things
inevitably go south you can also mix up
your party members so their abilities
complement one another for example
adding in buddies who can execute knock
backs and reverse knock backs save your
farts what a weird game and what a weird
sentence but seriously in combat you'll
get the chance to use a special time
fight which reverses time and lets you
deny your opponent's turn it's an
absolutely crucial Hail Mary especially
when you need one more turn to heal or
avoid being decimated by a bosses
onslaught just make sure you trigger the
time fight before your opponent's turn
ends or you'll be stuck wearing that
damage conversely in more casual field
battles go ahead and use your fights as
often as possible to knock these fights
over quickly on that topic save your
summons to summons include a brutal AoE
attack gifted to you by Jimbo and a
helping hand from Moses who heals your
whole party these are limited though you
can occasionally find extra Macaroni to
craft new summons for Moses that those
are scarce and the other summons can be
completely depleted so make sure you're
only using them when you absolutely have
to steal things and explore just like
you would in stick of truth be sure to
open every gold knob to draw Locker and
backpack you come across in every
building and leave no box unbroken now
that you have the chance to craft it's a
good idea to have a big backlog of
crafting supplies ensuring that you're
searching every nook and cranny in South
Park is the way to do that if you need
extra scrap for biohazards or crafting
go ahead and punch bins and mailboxes
they're full of everybody else's trash
which just so happens to be your
treasure on top of that make sure you
head back to your house whenever the toy
box
pops up on the city map as it means
there are rewards waiting for you
navigating mission items dirt by mission
items unless the game has told you
there's no other option I believe 20
bucks buying a gin and tonic emission
item immediately before picking one up
on a table and another in a bag at the
back of the peppermint hippo simply
because it was listed as a quest item
this might be more about my inadequacies
than your tips but it's better than oh
now then lose half your cash speaking of
mission items the game won't always hold
your hand from objective to objective
particularly when it comes to side
quests if you're lost or not sure what
you're supposed to do next pay attention
to the messages you receive in your
Costa gram feed you can also find clues
about what to do next by reading the
descriptions associated with mission
items you pick up these won't
necessarily be associated with quests
you've already obtained so sometimes
you'll have to work it out yourself for
example you might pick up a key that
unlocks a garage that you previously
couldn't access and reading the
description will tell you where to go
these are just a few of the things I've
discovered but let me know what useful
things you figured out while playing the
fractured but whole be sure to check out
our review on site and I will catch you
next time